yeah i mean like i feel like families
obviously very important to you yeah
been a big theme of both your projects
um on mama's hood you talk about your
boy who you lost yeah for sure i was
just on the phone with it with his mom
too literally yesterday juwan ross i was
on the phone with his mom
and um
my bad i was just thinking out loud no
but i was just saying like um
that that was like a kind of a crazy
verse yeah i feel like there's so many
people who probably
have been in that position where they
got a friend who like you know
they like you know did you like it felt
like you had some sort of guilt like
yeah for sure survival's guilt yeah like
i think that's a real thing and i think
a lot of people go through that so to
hear you talk about it and like i don't
i don't think like people might have
expected that from you because i think
we look at you as kind of like
you know like um
not a street rapper yeah for sure like
to to know that one of your best friends
got into a shootout and passed away and
like how that made you feel was like you
know a pretty vulnerable moment on the
album was that something that like
happened and you knew right away i gotta
i gotta make sure i share this with the
world it's it was a kind of like therapy
no it wasn't more so i gotta share it
with the world um it just happened
i wrote that song the week you know i
found out he got killed and uh this is
somebody i'm with every day in high
school we play basketball together
um even when i go to college he used to
always come up and visit me and
you know um
and all these things so when he got
killed man i just felt like guilty like
man i could have saved them like i
single-handedly i felt like man i might
as well pull the trigger because i could
have just saved him you know and um
when that beat came on it just gave me
like those vibes and um i say that to
say that uh
it's unfortunate that it takes you know
like i said a lot of my music it it's a
real life experience just transmuted
into emotions and musical form and
unfortunately sometimes it's something
as tragic as that sparks a song you know
and um yeah it's a crazy thing man it's
an unfortunate part of life like i lost
a lot of people that i grew up with rest
in peace a little tony um rest in peace
fly brandon and one of my friends got
killed in middle school brandon um tony
got killed right after we graduated
juwan and it's just so many people i
grew up with you know that i'm with day
to day we live in the same neighborhood
this and that and i'm like
be a day later i'm like damn we're just
walking home from school together they
getting killed you know and so it just
really been bugging me because it's
something that
i've gotten used to you know people that
i'm with every day and going to school
with
getting either killed prematurely before
they're 18 years old in some cases
um or getting locked up for a super long
time and it's something i've like grown
accustomed to used to to where like i
may not even shed a tear you know on and
it's not because i'm not empathetic or i
love them i'll miss them but because i'm
just so used to the [ __ ] and i'm
thinking it's normalized to me so i'm
thinking it's normal when i'm talking to
other people about they like nah you get
desensitized yeah exactly